your share price under pressure a lot of
concerns about whether you can pull this
off it's a huge deal how much do you
need the deal and how confident are you
that you will be able to push it through
well first of all thanks for having me
Francine and we are very excited about
the offer for Monsanto which we
submitted you kind of indicated the
headline share price and the company
valuation we see that this is a great
opportunity to drive our science and
innovation based business model going
forward with the strengths of Monsanto
we are very much convinced that this is
a value proposition for the montanta
shareholders and we are also convinced
and fully committed to this transaction
do you think that you will get
shareholder backing on your side and
when are you expecting to have an answer
from Monsanto well we are starting today
to communicate many things that our
shareholders needs in order to assess
the quality and the great value
proposition of this offer not only for
nominal to shareholders but also for our
shareholders we have in the past always
gone where we can create superior value
and if you look at the history of the
company over the last ten years we have
trade reports the value of our share and
that is very much driven by the
significant and transformational
transactions we have done in other
segments of our portfolio bidding
consumer health or in pharma right also
most recently with the IPO of
cholesterol mr. Bauman a Citigroup and
Peter Frodo take your debt out 242
billion euros critically they don't see
return on invested capital doing better
than cost of capital until 2023 can your
shareholders wait for an ROI C return
that goes out five years or six years or
seven years
well there are a number of things that
need to be understood with our offer I
cannot relate to the figures you quoted
let me tell you how we see the value
creation of this transaction actually as
a matter of fact in the first year after
closing the transaction already we see
double-digit earnings per share
accretion and with that also the ability
to pay a higher dividend to our
shareholders starting from the second
year this will be a double-digit
increase about roughly that it is what
it's going to be over and above our
current stand alone and then in terms of
return on capital and whack after the
third year yeah and not way into the
2020s the way obviously some people
calculate we will be earning the cost of
capital and the premium thereafter yeah
so it is actually a fairly rapidly
value-creating value proposition we have
and that's actually why we are so
convinced about this there's any number
of ways to go here and I want to point
out to Peter at Citigroup does agree
that it has double-digit accretive
really in the first year the
shareholders speak what I'd like to know
mr. Baumann is how beholden is your 42
billion euros of debt to the policies of
Mario Draghi and other central bankers
you've got the gift of free money what
happens to your company what happens to
this transaction if interest rates go up
well first of all we look of course at a
well-blended financing structure with
maturities that align with our ability
to generate free cash flows and with it
the ability to also deliver that is
something that is something that is a
core element of prudent financial policy
and you may have seen the statement of
Standard & Poor's in assessing what the
financial structure and the balance
sheet of Bayeux is going to look like
going forward and we are actually very
pleased because it is an indication that
we are going to have a very solid
investment grade rating going forward
and also the chance to attain an
excellent business profile for rating
purposes right Francine berenberg just
publishing berenberg capital and I would
suggest they say that this transaction
makes strong strategic sense but
Francine they look for Monsanto to beg
for a higher offer right and this is
where I was going to ask the CEO mr.
Bauman if Monsanto Vernor actually
rejects your offer are you ready or do
you have a capacity to increase the
offer we are totally convinced about the
attractiveness of our offer if you look
at the fact that it is a 37 percent
premium over and above the unaffected
share price as of May 9th I think that's
a strong testimony to the value
proposition for Monsanto shareholders it
is also in line with some of the
transactions or attempted transactions
which we saw in the past and we are
fully convinced that that is a highly
attractive offer
for Monsanto sport and also their share
final offer
or is it just your first it is the best
offer is the best and strong offer we
are waiting for the response of the
board of directors of Monsanto Vernor
one final question berenberg Capital
Alastair Campbell having a lot of fun
this morning are you going to name the
company base Anto well it is too early
to speculate about what the name of the
company is going to be but let me tell
you that bears name and bears reputation
stand for science innovation and an
utmost level of responsibility for
societal needs and that is what we are
going to leverage on also for the
combined company going forward you don't
see any major regulatory risks to the
Monsanto deal have you discussed the
deal with any major regulators that have
already given you the implicit
greenlight well you know given the
private character of the discussions up
and until now we have certainly done our
homework internally with our internal
and external expertise we have at the
table but we have not gone so far at
this point in time and involved external
regulators
that will then be one of the next steps
going forward